- [Voiceover] In a previous
video, we figured out how
to find the surface
area of this cereal box
by figuring out the areas
of each of the six surfaces
of the box, and then adding them all up.
I'm going to do that again in this video,
but I'm going to do it by
visualizing a net for the box.
The way I think about a net of a box
like this, is what
would happen if you were
to cut the cardboard and
then flatten it all out?
So what am I talking about?
Well, what we have here, we could imagine
making a cut in the box,
and the cut could be,
let's see, I could make a cut back here,
So I could make a cut right over there,
I could cut it...
I could cut it right like
this, I could cut it like that.
So if I just did that, this top flap would
flap open so that would
be able to come out
like that, and then I could also
make a cut for this side.
So I could make a cut back there,
and I could make a cut right over here,
and now this side could flap forward,
and I could do the same thing on
this other side right over here.
Then that could flap forward,
and then, the back side, I could draw it.
So I would also have a cut.
I'll draw it as a dotted line because
you're not supposed to
be able to see this cut.
But the corresponding cut to this one
on the side that we can't see,
we can draw it a little
bit neater than that.
The corresponding cut
would be right back here.
Right back there, and then
a cut right over here.
And so what would happen
if we were to flatten all of this out?
Well we would have,
we would have the front of the box.
I'll try to draw this as neatly as I can.
So the front of the box looks like this.
We would have this top
flap, which looks like this
If we were to flatten it all out.
We have these two side flaps.
So that's a side flap.
That's a slide flap.
And this is another, this
side flap right over here.
That's a side flap.
Then we would have the bottom of the box.
So the bottom of the box
is going to look like this.
The bottom of the box.
And then we have the back of the box.
That the bottom is going
to be connected to.
We didn't cut that.
So we have the back of the box.
The back of the box looks like this.
And there we have it.
We've made the net.
This is what would happen if you
made the cuts that I talked about
and then flatten the box
out, it would look like this.
Now how can we use this net
to find the surface area?
Well we just need to figure out
the surface area of this shape now.
So how do we do that?
Well we know a lot about the dimensions.
We know that this width right over here,
that this is ten centimeters.
Ten centimeters from there to there.
We know the height, actually,
going all the way from
here all the way up.
Because the height of the
box is 20 centimeters,
so this is going to be 20
centimeters right over here.
And you have another 20 centimeters,
you have another 20
centimeters right over here.
And right over here if you like.
And then you have, see
the depth of the box
is three centimeters, so
this is three centimeters.
Three centimeters, and then
And so what is the area,
actually just let me do one region first.
What is the area of this entire region
that I am shading in with this blue color?
Well it's ten centimeters, that is,
I'll do a color that you
can see a bit more easily.
It is ten centimeters
wide, ten centimeters.
Times, what's the height?
20, plus three, plus 20, plus three.
So that's going to be 40 plus
six, so times 46 centimeters.
That's this blue area.
So that's going to be 460,
460 square centimeters.
460 square centimeters, and now we just
have to figure out the
area of the two flaps.
So this flap right over here
is 20 centimeters by three centimeters.
So that's 60 centimeters squared.
So 60 centimeters squared,
or 60 square centimeters I should say.
And then this flap is going
to have the exact same area.
Another 60 square centimeters.
60 square centimeters, and
you add everything together.
We deserve a little bit of a drumroll.
We get, well this is going to add up to
580 square centimeters.
Which is the exact thing
we got in the other video
where we didn't use a
net, and you should just,
it's nice to be able to do it either way.
To be able to visualize the net
or to be able to look
at this and think about
the different sides, even the sides that
you might not necessarily see.